this video was brought to you by the
lovely people at my patreon
2020 is over and i think i speak for all
of us when i say
thank god amongst other things 2020 was
a significant year for
climate change but in the new year 2021
we have some very exciting big
developments to look
forward to so i just want to spend a
couple of minutes talking about five
things you should be on the lookout for
in climate change coverage in 2021
firstly chinese climate policy china
currently emits about 30
of the world's greenhouse gases it's the
world's largest emitter and so what it
chooses to do in the field of climate
action
is massively significant and last year
xi jinping dropped an absolutely huge
bomb the chinese premier
announced that the nation would peak its
carbon emissions by
2030 and be carbon neutral by 2060.
although exactly what he meant by that
is a little
unclear to use technical terminology
this would be a pretty bloody big deal
especially as china has met its
historical climate commitments
although those climate commitments were
much smaller
than this enormous pledge the thing to
look out for in 2021
is china announcing how it plans to do
this
because obviously we're living through a
post-covered recovery and china's
recovery has largely been based on high
carbon
energy and infrastructure which is for
the record exactly what i said it would
be in a previous video
excellent analysis by carbon brief
indicates that china has committed to
investing
three times as much money in new fossil
fuel-based projects as it has
to investing in green energy projects
so i would guess that this year possibly
at the cop conference which we'll come
to
later in the video it would make a raft
of new investment announcements and
perhaps specifically in energy
infrastructure so allowing for
a greater integration of renewable
energy into its grid keep an
eye out for a quite probably very public
announcement like that from china
because if it happens
that's a huge step forward in lowering
global greenhouse gas emissions
of course china is not the only
superpower going into 2021
we also have a new administration in
america
to say that donald trump's presidency
was bad news for the environment would
be
an understatement however in 2021 we can
look forward to the presidency of
joe biden because he won
the election president-elect biden has
laid out some fantastically ambitious
plans for climate action having been
influenced by people on the left of the
democratic party
amongst other things biden has announced
that he will be rejoining america into
the paris agreement on his first day in
office pledges to make america carbon
neutral by 2050
and has laid out a truly ambitious 2
trillion dollar investment strategy for
greenifying the american economy however
he might struggle to accomplish this
this is because at the moment biden can
only really influence such things via
executive orders which are
limited in scope and can be undone by
the next president whoever
that may be to effect further changes
biden's democratic party would have to
take control of the us senate which is
currently controlled by the republicans
and considering their environmental
credentials are roughly on par with
those of cyril sneer
that means they're almost certainly
going to block his two trillion dollar
investment plan this is why the next
piece of climate news to watch out for
is the
georgia senate runoff race this january
if the democrats can take the two seats
up for grabs there then they can
effectively take control of the senate
on issues related to
tax and spending and so biden could
realistically push through
his plan if a republican wins that's
going to be a lot more difficult so this
is a really crucial moment for climate
action the next thing to watch out for
is arguably the headline event
of the year cop 26 taking place in
glasgow
this november cop stands for conference
of parties it's basically the united
nations
annual climate change conference it was
meant to happen in glasgow in 2020
but because of the pandemic it got
delayed year which may
have been an absolutely crucial delay
and good news
these cop events happen every year and
in 2019
there was meant to be a discussion of
nations agreeing to further carbon
emission
cuts and effectively strengthening up
the promises they made in the paris
agreement those decisions however were
kicked down the road to cop26
in 2020 largely thanks to the action of
a couple of
nations if the conference had taken
place in 2020 then those same nations
quite possibly would
have actually had the same objections
but
in 2021 america is under new
administration the biden administration
is very keen to apparently commit
to further climate action and china's xi
jinping is much the same stories
committed to making china's emissions
peak before 2030.
so those are two very significant
nations who have been moved from one
side of the argument to the other
those advocating for emissions cuts so
it is possible that cop 26 could see
some
real fireworks in terms of commitments
to future carbon cuts
now admittedly we shouldn't get too
excited because previous conference of
parties
have not exactly been the most effective
and also nations are feeling the
financial pinch of a post-covert
recovery so they might be reluctant to
commit to
green spending at this point in time but
there is a chance that we could see some
really significant pledges made in
november this year
next 2020 was kicked off by some
exceptional wildfires in
australia an event which was almost
certainly exacerbated
by climate change now it's unlikely that
we'll see similar
fires in australia this year the
conditions aren't exactly right
but another place that we should be on
the lookout for some exceptional weather
this year
is the south western united states
climate change combined with la nina
conditions in the pacific ocean have led
to the southwestern united states
being warmer and drier than average and
we expect those conditions
to continue across the spring of 2021
the us government has put out a warning
saying that the wildfire season this
spring
could be particularly bad in the
southwest united states
so whilst we're not seeing the same kind
of events as we saw in australia and
it hopefully won't be quite that
dramatic i would keep an eye on the news
of wildfires in america
this year not just in spring but also in
summer we can expect the intensity and
frequency of events like these to
both increase as we continue to warm the
planet so
this kind of phenomenon would certainly
match what climate science was
telling us to expect if you do live
somewhere where there is a wildfire
season please
do stay safe and then lastly is 2021
going to be a record-breaking year for
global temperatures
probably not as i just mentioned the
pacific ocean is currently in its la
nina phase which basically means the
ocean is slightly cooler than usual
and that doesn't sound like very much of
a big deal but whether the pacific is in
el nino
or la nina conditions is a large part of
what determines the global average
temperature anomaly 2020 was on track to
be the warmest year on
record but at the tail end of the year
these la nina conditions develop which
just
slightly lowered the global average
temperature
and that was enough to just knock it
below 2016 which is the current record
holder
however that's kind of extraordinary
because in 2016
we saw a huge super el nino event which
warmed up the pacific massively and it
effectively warmed the entire planet and
what's happened in the four years since
then
is humanity has warmed the planet enough
that the largest internal driver
of changes to the earth's surface
temperature was swinging so hard in one
direction in 2016 and
relatively hard in the other direction
in 2020 and we
basically just negated that like humans
in the course of four years have
effectively changed the climate as much
as the biggest possible swimming from el
nino could
and that's terrifying as we're going
into 2021 with la nina conditions
it's unlikely that we would eclipse
2016's level of warming unless a large
el nino event were to develop in the
tail end of the year which is
possible but then again maybe humans
have influenced the climate enough in
just the past 12
months to elevate us beyond the record
set in 2016.
we don't know we're kind of in
unchartered territory so if the fifth
thing to look out for in 2021
isn't the global average temperature
change which i mean i'd argue really you
should be looking at it anyway somewhat
the point then the number to look out
for
is this number this is the total amount
of carbon we have added to the
atmosphere
to date if this number gets above 1
trillion
that's really the kind of climate change
we want to try and avoid
so i'm going to put a link to this
website down there trillion ton
in the description and just check in
every now and again over the course of
the year keep an eye on it
because what is this number going to be
by the end of the year
i don't know how low can we make it
let's try and make it as low as possible
thank you very much for watching
this video it was a little different for
me i wanted to put together a little
something that was kind of
i don't know almost like climate news do
let me know if you enjoyed it and do let
me know if you think i missed anything
significant down there in the comments
there's so much stuff to talk about i
just wanted to limit it to five
so i'm sure there's gonna be plenty of
interesting discussion thank you also to
the wonderful people over on my patreon
who support me and this channel your
support means that i
have a guaranteed amount of income every
month i can pay bills and i can actually
focus on making the best videos i can
which is the most wonderful thing you
could give a creator so
to all my patrons thank you so much
here's some suggested viewing for you
next if you enjoyed the video do
please pop it a like and share it with
other people if you think they should
see it too
and well that just leaves me to say
thanks so much for watching
i'll see in the next one